la audiencia empezaba a las nueve y
media de la mañana hora local pero
termino empezando a las diez y media de
la mañana porque el ex gerente de la
campaña de donald trump build stepien no
se presentó y terminó enviando un
comunicado esto retrasó entonces la
segunda audiencia el testimonio que más
ha llamado la atención ha fue el de el
ex fiscal general de donald trump
william board que lo acompañó durante
gran parte de su administración pero que
al final renunció a su cargo porque
simplemente según él los argumentos de
fraude electoral del ex presidente de
anoche no se sostenían textualmente dijo
que estaban alejados desconectados de la
realidad y que a pesar de que don orione
sabía que su argumento de fraude no se
sostenía porque no tenía pruebas siguió
adelante con este argumento muchos se
preguntan entonces y varios de los
presentes en esta audiencia responden
que el ex presidente siguió adelante con
su argumento de fraude electoral
precisamente porque este argumento le
sirvió para recoger fondos millonarios
fondos para su campaña precisamente
argumentando este fraude electoral entre
los que están llamados a testificar hoy
también están 20 min james burke que fue
es un abogado republicano también el
fiscal big buck y también auschwitz que
es comisionado por filadelfia cristóbal
que sigue ahora en este proceso es decir
cuántas audiencias más van a existir y
qué podría pasar después de las
audiencias
y para el mes de junio se espera que
sean cinco audiencias el miércoles de
esta semana habrá otra audiencia
tratando de responder otra de las siete
preguntas que se quieren responder en
estas audiencias y se espera que en
septiembre sea la última audiencia los
demócratas han agendado esta última
audiencia septiembre teniendo en cuenta
obviamente las elecciones de noviembre
para poder hacer mayor impacto de cara a
estas elecciones
legislativas y pues hay que resaltar que
la decisión final sobre si se imputa al
cargos en contra del expresidente donoso
está en manos del departamento de
justicia que recogería está evidencia
que me presenta el congreso para sabes
hacer seguir adelante o no con los
cargos contra el ex presidente